Lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es pensar en la relación entre dos variables,
y pensar en
¿cómo se vería esta relación en una gráfica?
digamos que aquí,
estoy dibujando dos ejes
en el eje horizontal
está el precio de un producto
y en el eje vertical
la demanda de ese producto...
demanda del producto...
y sólo voy a dibujar
el primer cuadrante de estos ejes
asumiendo que el precio va a ser positivo
y la demanda también va a ser positiva.
¿Qué va a pasar cuando un precio es muy bajo?
si el precio es bajo,
podemos asumir que muchas personas
van a querer comprar ese producto,
por el precio barato,
si el precio es barato...
entonces la demanda va a ser muy alta,
si el precio fuera 0 la demanda sería altísima,
aquí lo podemos poner
demanda alta
y el precio 0
si el precio aumentará un poco
pues podríamos pensar
que la demanda disminuiría un poco
Si el precio
vuelve a aumentar un poquito más
la demanda va a ser menor
entonces vamos a dibujarlo aquí.
Si el precio aumentara más, pues habría menos personas que podrían comprarlo o pagar ese precio
así que la demanda
va a ir disminuyendo
si el precio fuera muy, muy, muy grande
la demanda sería muy pequeña
y podemos dibujar este comportamiento
como esta línea magenta
esta línea que va hacia abajo
así que esto es la gráfica de la demanda
con respecto al precio
puede ser curva hacia abajo o curva hacia arriba,
pero más o menos
es esta la idea
si ustedes ven
esta curva como la línea magenta
si el precio aumenta,
¿pues qué pasa con la demanda?
aquí va aumentando el precio
y voy a ver el valor de la demanda
ah, pues va disminuyendo.
Ahora vamos a ver otro escenario...
vamos a imaginar
la demanda de de un terreno
y vamos a poner aquí abajo
en el eje horizontal la población...
de una región
y en el eje vertical
va a estar la demanda por terreno...
por terreno
Si no hay gente en esta área,
si la población es muy, muy pequeña
tendiendo a 0,
nadie va a querer comprar terreno ahí
cuando la población es 0,
la demanda
por terreno será 0 también
conforme aumenta la población
la demanda por el terreno
va a aumentar
si hay mucha gente en esa área
muchas personas
van a estar queriendo comprar terrenos para vivir
así que la gráfica de relación de la demanda de terreno con respecto a la población, va a ser así,
aunque puede variar un poquito pero
la idea es que si ustedes ven una gráfica así
y a ustedes les preguntan, cuando aumenta la población, ¿qué pasa con la demanda de terreno?
Ah bueno, pues aumenta,
aquí lo estamos viendo
vemos este valor de población que va aumentando
y vemos otro valor de la demanda que corresponde
y vemos que está aumentando
a diferencia del ejemplo anterior en el que al aumentar
el precio disminuye la demanda.
Ahora voy a dibujar un ejemplo más general
en el que no voy a estar
dando ejemplos específicos
pero si yo tengo este diagrama
en el eje horizontal tengo "x"
en el  vertical a "y" y les preguntan,
¿qué pasa con la variable "y" cuando "x" se incrementa?
Bueno, aquí elijo un punto en "x",
veo el correspondiente en "y"
si aumento este valor de "x",
voy a ver cuál es el valor de "y" correspondiente
y en este caso veo que está aumentando
así que en este caso, "y" va a aumentar
mientras "x" se incrementa,
"y" también se incrementa
aquí lo escribimos,
cuando "x" se incrementa, "y" se incrementa.
Aquí vamos a escribir
otro ejemplo genérico
en el eje horizontal tengo "a",
en el eje vertical tengo a "b"
y esta es la gráfica, esta línea.
¿Que pasa cuando "a" incrementa?
Bueno en este caso hago lo mismo,
elige un valor de "a"
veo el valor correspondiente en "b"
y si aumento el valor de a hacia la derecha
¿qué pasa con el valor de "b"?
veo un punto de "a" hacia la derecha
y veo que en este punto
el valor de "b" es menor
así que cuando aumenta "a",
"b" va a disminuir o a decrementarse.
Entonces para que tengan la idea general
cuando ven este tipo de gráfica
en la que "x" y "y" aumentan,
la línea de la gráfica,
va a tener una pendiente hacia arriba,
cuando la "x" se incrementa,
la "y" incrementa también,
por lo que está pendiente se va a elevar.
Ahora en el otro caso,
cuando tenemos una variable que aumenta
y la otra decrementa
se dice que
la pendiente va hacia abajo
como pueden ver,
está pendiente disminuye.